all right let's get this session started
thanks for coming to the last session
before the free afternoon I know you
have a choice and you can also just
start your afternoon adventures early so
thanks for coming so let's start the
session with a talk on a new quantum
algorithm it's gonna be an efficient
quantum algorithm for the principle
ideal problem and class group problem in
arbitrary degree number fields the talks
gonna begin by Jean Francois BS and its
joint work with thanks on thank you so
first I would like to specify that it's
not completely new and it says on the
slide it was worked from 2016 that was
presented that about a year ago by Fang
at the soda conference theoretical
computer science so it's like a year old
so it concerns the search for solutions
to problems in computational number
theory for which we can propose
exponentially faster solutions using
quantum computers ok that's been like
that's been an important motivation for
quantum information theory showing that
there are computational problems for
which quantum computers clearly
outperform the classical ones so one
really famous example is the factoring
and discrete logarithm resolution
quantum algorithm from Peter Short
it's been also the main motivation for
the creation of an entire new field of
cryptography they call post quantum
cryptography because as you know most of
the public key crypto that is deployed
to these dates relies on on the harness
of factoring and based on the same sort
of framework there has been other
quantum algorithm described to solve
some other related computational tasks
and number theory so some of some of
them are computing the in group of a
number field computing the ideal class
group of a number field solving what's
called the principle ideal problem which
consists of finding generators finding a
generator of a principal ideal
and for these well it's been a process
so first for during the past decade that
has been solutions that were proposed
for dealing with instances where the
families of inputs that were considering
live in fixed degree number fields and
then recently there has been a
breakthrough where the Union group of
nama field was calculated in in
polynomial time even for arbitrary
degree and it's it's work from isin
triger hall grant dive and my co-author
fencing song so in this work we're I
mean in this presentation I'm gonna show
how we extended the work of Eisen Trager
and her co-authors to other problems in
number theory which includes principle
idea Parliament class Gopala move up as
I'll show it's actually we have a wide
variety of problems that we can solve
using the same general framework so as I
said we have a wide variety of problems
the original motivation was the
resolution of the principle idea problem
in the class group because usually in
most of the previous work the previous
state of the art the Union group the
principle idea problem in the closet
will always solve together more or less
turns out that we realized that we had
to and it's something that we'll discuss
later during this talk we had to rely on
the computation of a different object
and from this computation here computing
the what's called es units and I'm gonna
describe what it is later during the
talk then you have a solution you can
derive solutions to all sorts of
computational problems in number theory
that includes our original motivation
but in fact you have you have more than
aa includes things like related class
groups summer groups and and
and yeah and maybe more that we haven't
even thought about so the so these are
problems and number theory that you know
just to define those problems and as the
objects that we're computing it if I
want to make a self-contained
presentation of those those problem is
gonna take quite a what quite a long
time and eat a certain proportion of my
talk so what I want to do is I want to
justify the study of the principle idea
problem and norm equations and I want to
say well and this talk I want to say as
little as possible about number theory
okay and focus on on the quantum the
quantum algorithms that we used so I'm
gonna motivate the study of the
principle idea problem with post quantum
cryptography which as I said is a great
source of motivation for the description
of quantum algorithms and also norm
equations because it's kind of easy to
see how this intersects very fundamental
problems in number theory so a norm
equation
it's the an equation of the form norm of
in elements in the field equals
something okay and this particular
example taken from the nice Emil's PhD
thesis tells you that one other way to
reformulate this norm equation is this
equation here so when you don't know the
definition of the norm norm equation
it's hard to get excited about it but
when you see here that there is actually
a simple equivalent formulation of this
norm equation then then you understand
that that this is this is a very
fundamental problem in number theory and
it's known as it's known as Hilbert 10th
problem the resolution I mean the
deciding whether an equation of this
form has integral solutions is a is a
fundamental problem which in fact does
not have any general solution so that
put differently there is no general
algorithm to solve a different equation
however we do
generally quicker than to solve a norm
equation which means we have a large
variety of norm equations for which I
mean of such die fanta equations for
which we know how to provide
systematically solution and taken from
Denis Simone's thesis you know the
solutions are of this form and that's
not really important what's important is
that it can decide this our rational
solution they can decide that in fact
there are no integral solutions so
really providing an answer to the
problem whether or not that this
decision problem whether or not there is
a solution to such an equation now from
a more practical perspective in
cryptography there has been a lot of
schemes described that used lattices and
then for the sake of efficiency people
have used lattices that in fact live in
in number fields which which are ideals
in fact and it turns out that if you
know how to solve the principle ideal
problem efficiently then like other
works other recent works have shown that
in fact this threatens the security of
those new proposals relying on idea
lattices so for example some proposals
have decided to rely on the hardness of
I mean we assumed the presume hardness
of finding a short generator of a
principle ideal and that includes a
variety of schemes such as well I
mentioned the multi linear Maps okay
that's that's one things that they liked
about those schemes that they would
allow you to do some kind of multi-part
i'ts key exchange but also people have
proposed those sorts of schemes because
they would allow them to achieve fully
homomorphic encryption which is another
crucial stake in cryptography and also
they thought at some point that because
it was relying on on lattices in high
dimension perhaps it was going to be
quantum safe and that didn't go well and
I didn't go
because in recent work from chrome or
dukkha peickert and Rajesh it was shown
that finding a short generator is not
really that much harder as finding a
generator and combine them with this
work finding a generator it can be done
in polynomial time with a corner
computer now there has been also other
another family of schemes that rely on
the so-called ring learning with error
problem and well the security the proof
of security of this problem is it relies
on the assumption that an approximate
solution I mean it is hard to find
approximate solutions to what's called
the short vector problem we call it SVP
and when we say proximate solution well
it means finding a vector the whose
length is within a factor gamma of the
shortest vector of your lattice now it
turns out that so there has been even
more recent work from crime Erdogan
vasilevsky that said that in fact for
some approximation factors gamma the the
reduction there as VP the gamma is VP
reduces to the the problem of finding a
generator in a principal ideal so again
a problem for which we're providing a
polynomial time quantum solution so why
this is interesting
well because then here again we have an
example of quantum algorithm outperforms
the best known classical algorithm by
superpolynomial improvement factor here
the bkz algorithm would solve gamma is
vp for the same gamma in time that is
what is exponential square with n and
here we present an under that heuristic
reduction would present that Buridan
that that would solve the same problem
in polynomial time
now just the word about the implication
security implications with respect to R
inaudible UE I'm not saying any of it is
broken
first of all because the the proof of
security of ring lwe under the
assumption that gamma is we
his heart is only for very small gammas
so the kind of gammas that we have here
does not threaten that that proof of
security and even if you did fun if you
did find an algorithm that solves SVP it
does not necessarily mean it will find
you the solutions to the Ring LW problem
it's just a security reduction okay so
just want to make sure that I'm not
claiming we broke anything in this work
but it is really relevant now here is
the general outline of of how so how
this how this worked out so we have a
bunch of problems so principalía problem
clause group norm equation and dot for
many other problem I mean some other
problems that in number theory that we
found we found interesting and these we
show that they for the most part
classically we reduce to the problem of
finding s units in your number field
okay so that's mostly classical in the
dot does the rate classical problem in
fact that one you need and you need an
Oracle for discrete logs and and
factorization so it's not quite
classical but for the most part every
all the techniques that will reduce
these problems to as units is
essentially classical and then we are
going to show that this is this can be
turned into an instance of the so-called
hidden subgroup problem and then we're
going to show how how the instance of
the hidden subgroup problem we can use
the state-of-the-art
known from the honker in eisentrager
greg- and song paper
ok so first I'm gonna remind the
audience of what the hidden sub problem
is and and which exact algorithms were
using to solve the hidden star poem
because there's been many variants of
this poem describes then I'm gonna
finally say a little more about es units
and how the fact that how computing the
s Union group
reduces to an instance of the hidden
subway problem so the hidden Starwood
problem so the its there has been
several interesting polymers and
computational problems and I'm a theory
that can be reduced to the problem of
finding a subgroup of a certain group
from G okay and the way the way it's
usually done and here I'm not giving
details with the way it's usually done
is to say well let F be a function okay
and a function that goes from my group
to quantum states and then if basically
if that function satisfy the property
that f of X plus y equals f of X if and
only if Y is in my secret subgroup then
we say that F hides the subgroup okay
and so there has been some so there has
been a large body of work devoted to the
resolution of the hidden several problem
and the tricky case is when you're
dealing with subgroups of our to the M
because the discretization causes
troubles when the degree goes to
infinity so and in the so in in in
eisentrager Cochran gif and song 2014
they got rid of that problem but the
previous state of the art it was limited
to cases where you would discourage
art to the M for a fixed M okay so
here's how it works
you want your function from R to the M
to quantum states you so you first of
all you want it to hide your your your
subgroup H which will ultimately I mean
whose knowledge will give you the
solution to your problem and so what it
means is essentially that you know when
you have x and y in h h- y + h so x
equals y mod h then you should get the
same quantum state but you need extra
you need extra conditions so and this
this comes from the work of eisentrager
and
and her co-authors you need extra pop
booties on that function basically tell
you that when you have when you take the
states that are that rise from points
that are very close together in your in
your in our to the M then you will get
states quantum states that are very
close and when you we look at the states
that come from points that are far a
would they say far apart then that the
quantum states were going to be close to
orthogonal and of course this is a hand
waving sort of description of that that
they are more rigorous more rigorous
definitions of what I mean by if X is
far from Y then the states are
orthogonal and if they're close then the
states are close together okay and then
given a function that satisfies those
conditions and only if it does satisfy
those conditions then you can apply the
quantum solver for the hidden subgroup
problem so I will need the notion of the
lattice and also it's now is a good
moment to describe what the lattice is
because what you're looking at here when
you apply the hidden subgroup Parliament
are to the M you're looking at a
subgroup a discreet subgroup of our to
the M which turns out to be a lattice
and what lattice is it's the all the
integer linear combinations of a set of
points in R to the M so in dimension two
for example it looks like a grid and so
they can be defined by you know the
basis of those two vectors or it can be
defined by these vectors but at the end
what it looks like it's an infinite grid
made of all the red dots here so that is
a lattice okay and we're gonna need what
we're gonna need to do here is we're
gonna have to say well we want to
compute those s units that's our goal
and we have to say well finding the HTS
units is going to be the same as finding
a lattice in our to the M and that I'm
gonna give a little more details so that
problem of identifying your the solution
to a problem computational Parliament
number theory as the search of a lattice
in R to the M or a subgroup of a G of G
is not new it started off I mean the
problem of factoring integers can be
reformulated as a solution to the hidden
subgroup problem in Z and then finding
that such finding discrete logs can also
be reformulated as a solution to the
hidden subgroup problem and then it's
been known that Union group principally
pollen class group these are all
problems that could be rewritten as I
mean reformulate it as the search for a
subgroup so it's not that idea itself is
not new but making it work in large
degree is the main contribution of our
of our paper and of course other
problems work for not a phenom
communitive group in particular I mean I
personally have worked in on on on
dihedral groups because they this the
hidden side would problem there can give
you for example the solution to the the
hidden shift problem which which can
arise in some computational problems
number theory as well so as I promised
I'm gonna give it a little bit of
details about what it is to compute as
units and what they are really before we
dive into the quantum reduction to the
hidden circle problem itself
so so number fields what they are so cue
the rationals is a number field and any
finite extension of Q is also a number
field now we're gonna need to talk about
ideals so so ideals the notion of
algebra it's a set in K that has nice
properties so the ideals of K they have
they have a variety of properties so
including that they're stable by
addition
okay it has its algebraic structure
they're stable by addition and also
they're stable by multiplication by an
integral elements
okay so ideals are sets in K but the
reason why they're called ideals is
because there's another property that
they have which is that they factor as a
product of prime a prime ideal so
certain ideals are primes and any ideal
can be written as a product of prime
ideals and that's the reason why they
were called ideals because the it's
ideal stands for ideal numbers so they
were described originally by Dedekind
because they wanted to what
mathematicians wanted to do was get rid
of the problem that it unlike unlike and
Q when you work and I'm a feel K that is
a anything like it strictly like a
non-trivial extension of Q you do not
have a unique factorization okay and
while those ideals they'll have a unique
factor they behave like like numbers
self respecting numbers which have the
property of unique factorization okay
and now when I say here I describe that
particular ideal okay which is a set
which contains alpha an element in K and
it is actually the smallest such I mean
the smallest ideal that contains alpha I
will call it the ideal generated by
alpha okay and that is essential in the
definition of the s units because given
a certain set of prime ideals then the s
units are all those alpha is such that
the corresponding principal ideal
factors as prime product of primes
that's only in s okay now if you want to
think about it as in terms of the simple
the simple example of Q well you could
say s equals the set of the primes 2 and
3 and the group of s units in Q would be
all those rational numbers that can be
written down as a power 3 times power 5
and what's interesting about that is it
can reformulate this by saying well it's
all those numbers such that you can
multiply them by
a power three and the power of five and
get one and that's this formulation
we're gonna use to express this whole
thing as as a subgroup and well the
principle idea problem since since we're
at since we're at it it's the problem of
finding alpha given the ideal generated
by alpha it's actually not an easy
problem and as I said here we were
getting rid of the of the nasty
dependency on on the degree of the field
they used to be exponential now let's
see how the nice properties of this unit
allows you so at that point I'm asking
you to trust me that all our problems
basically reduce to the problem of
computing s units and it's something
that I'm not going to give details on
because it's more on the number theory
side and not so much on the quantum
information side now we're gonna have to
see how we can turn this point of
competing s units into an instance of
the hidden subgroup problem so and again
here we're using the previous state of
the art where yeah what they were doing
they were using as units where they were
computing s units for a very particular
set S which is the empty set and first
of all they're mapping it into a lattice
as a lattice of art EDM and then there's
a two-step process to create a function
that hides this lattice first you find
each point here is associated to a
lattice in R to the N and then each
lattice is associated to a quantum state
so you have here a correspondence by
composition between elements in R to the
M and quantum states and we're doing
exactly the same we have a little bit of
extra information to keep but what we're
gonna do here is we're going to identify
s units as members of a sub lattice of R
to the N and times e to the K and these
guys will be mapped to lattices and then
to quantum states using the exact same
mapping here
now as I said before one way of
identifying an S Union is to say well
it's it's an element such that its
principle ideal multiplet can be
multiplied by certain powers of the PI's
to get the trivial ideal the trivial
idea is generated by one
not-so-surprising needs two units
multiplicative Li now the way we do it
is well here again I'm gonna have to ask
for a little bit of faith from the
audience
elements in your field can be mapped in
our to the M on a very canonical way
okay and then you're gonna take also
those valuations here the VI and then
you're gonna keep that extra information
and that means that there is a
correspondence between your units and
certain points in this lattice so sub
lattice that's in our to the M times e
to the K now it turns out you can also
use you can look at all these points
here whether or not they're in your
subgroup gamma is this or lambda s and
then there's an embedding in R to the M
of your fields and then you're gonna map
elements here to lattices in R to the N
and the way you do it is by saying well
I take the part that's in our to the M
and I map it to this lattice and I take
the part that's in Z to the K and I map
it to this lattice and if I happen to
hit an su net then I'll get the trivial
lattice and that trivial lattice behaves
really nice multiplicative ly in the
sense that every time I hit that trivial
lattice I reset so that's gonna give me
my function that hides the s Union group
so hah
here's how it works as I said before I
can define those two functions okay
given the parts of my input that is art
to the M I can calculate this lattice
and then given this part in Z to the K I
can calculate this line
and I can do that whether or not I'm
looking at a points that's an S unit it
may be complete gibberish it may be just
some random point in R to the N Z to the
K these two lattices will exist okay so
I can calculate them okay and I can
multiply them together and I get
something such that well why not get a
nice unit it gives me the tribute
lattice and when I do not get a nice
unit it just gives me a lattice okay now
what I want from this function that
hides my a student group is first of all
well that it hides the S Union group but
also I want that when when inputs are
close together
I want those lattices to be sort of
similar for a certain notion of you know
lattices being close together and when
they defer when they're far apart then I
also want that those lattices to defer
and that these are this is classical
information so we had to prove those
those two properties here to then use
the quantum encoding that was in
eisentrager halgren kita - songs paper
oops sorry
so we had to take that encoding that
takes a lattice in our t vm and then
derives a quantum states okay and given
the good properties that our classical
including of our information into
lattices have then and given the
properties of this encoding into quantum
states we have exactly what we want but
that property is really a combination of
first the classical encoding and then
the quantum encoding which was in
eisentrager and al paper and then when
you combine those two results you get
what you want which is essentially that
you can find your s unit efficiently
okay so to summarize so it's we had a
whole bunch of problems that we wanted
to calculate okay and we said that you
know all those problems
they were basically reducible to
paalam of finding s units in your number
field and that s unit problem we
expressed it as an instance of the
hidden subgroup problem and following
the same general strategy that was done
in in the eisentrager lager in Kiev and
song paper so and it worked and now of
course it opens up the natural question
like how can we even more generalize
this I mean the none clearly the non
abelian HSP problem will certainly
remain a challenge for for a long time
but there might be even in the abelian
case some polymers and I'm a theory that
we haven't considered so so yeah well
we're hoping to to work on that so thank
you for attention
[Applause]
hello Tekin thanks for the talk and we
have some time for questions yeah
I have one question so you said that in
some of those cases the reduction is
actually classical choice unions so I
was wondering that like for I mean that
that s is actually depends on your input
and so I was wondering if do you like me
to factor into actually compute the set
s for a given number field or no maybe I
should have I should have been more
clear about what s mean s is your input
Oh s is an input yes sorry okay but
sometimes well I mean when you for
example say okay you you want the
principle ideal problem well you have to
take your ideal and you're gonna have to
factor the ideal to determine which set
s you need for this production to give
you a solution to the principal idea
problem in this case okay you need to
construct in the in this particular in
general when you want an S unit group
you give as if that's the input now to
to use this reduction while every
problem has a different set s right and
you know that's my question
oftentimes there is factorization I mean
typically for the principal problem yeah
yeah and I thought of phenom equations
probably too late yes and also for the
rate class group okay there is a
discrete log more questions
so I haven't read your sort of ocean
paper before and I think that's my
window which paper your soda worship
paper okay so and I think that's
basically the same thing as what I was
showing here so what progress have you
made
I mean so far yep yes I mean I didn't
new things to tell well I mean we need
to clean up so in the soda soya is a is
a ten page paper so so then you know you
have it doesn't really allow you to give
a lot of details and in particular if
you have a long list of problems well we
only we basically only gave some details
on the principle idea problem in the
class core problem on the publish so a
paper and then towards the end we say oh
we listed a list of problem where you
said what we said well you know the
these are also following the same
framework would be solvable using the
same techniques and we gave you know the
general idea but we clearly didn't have
enough space to to develop those
reductions so first for example like
when when we we need we need to clarify
the reduction that the precise steps of
the reductions for each of the problems
that I mentioned before that I think is
is the immediate follow-up work that
we're doing so that it's clear because
so far we always said is yeah you know
it's it's it's easy to do it but now we
actually have to give details on that
okay things
maybe we have time for one quick
question maybe the next speaker can set
up well if there's one quick question
all right there no more questions let's
thank the speaker again
[Applause]